l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 373 de Monsieur Bernard
Fournier à madame la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche monsieur le Président Madame
le ministre mes chers collègues je
souhaite vivement attirer votre
attention et celle du gouvernement sur
l'intégration dans le schéma Licence
Master Doctorat de la formation des
masseurs kinési thérapeutes impulsé par
le processus de Bologne en 1999 voicii
14 ans la réforme L d implique la
modification du système d'enseignement
supérieur français en vue de la création
de l'espace européen l'enseignement
supérieur applicable dès la rentrée de
septembre 2013 le schéma arrêté en début
d'année prévoit la reconnaissance du
diplôme d'État de masseur
kinésiothérapeute au grade de licence
comme vous le savez l'Ordre des Masseurs
kinésiothérapeutes a toujours affirmé
que la qualité des soins passe
nécessairement par une formation de haut
niveau et un un diplôme universitaire au
grade de master malheureusement
l'arbitrage du 25 janvier 2013 que vous
avez signé conjointement avec madame la
ministre des Affaires sociales et de la
santé ne tient pas compte de ces
préconisations en effet par cette
décision le gouvernement confine la
formation professionnelle des masseurs
kinésithérapeutes dans le cadre étriqué
des 3 années d'études datant de 1969
sans tenir compte des évolutions et de
la for tion telle qu'elle est dispensée
réellement aujourd'hui de plus
l'arbitrage proposé n'est pas en
adéquation avec le programme défini par
le groupe de réingénerie depuis 5 années
il devait s'agir d'une réforme
d'envergure répondant aux évolution des
besoins de santé ainsi qu'aux attentes
de longues dates des professionnels de
santé il s'agit ici d'ayons pas peur des
mots d'un recul très clairement il faut
un nouvel arbitrage sur cette formation
tenant réellement compte de la réalité
d'exercice de la profession des masseurs
kinésithérapeutes les attentes de toutes
les composants de la profession sont
pourtant clair un master 1 pour
l'ensemble des masterurs
kinésithérapeutes et un Master 2 pour
ceux qui souhaitent poursuivre des
pratiques avancées le Master 1 définit
un niveau d'autorisation d'exercice
cohérent il serait dommageable de se
priver d'une réforme étant en phase la
profession avec l'évolution du rôle des
masterurs kinési et thérapeutes dans le
parcours de santé le Master 2 apportera
un complément d'expertise indispensable
à la profession et à la société en
conformité avec les nouvelles missions
dans le domaine notamment de la
coopération vous l'aurez compris je
crois qu'il est indispensable d'élaborer
une réforme de la formation initiale
permettant de proposer des études
conformes aux données actuel de la
science et aux besoins de la population
qui garantissent la qualité des soins et
la sécurité des patients en conséquence
je souhaite madame la ministre connaître
les mesures que vous envisager de
prendre en la matière afin de faire
rapidement évoluer les choses je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Madame
jeunevier fiorazo ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Sénateur Bernard Fournier alors le
diplôme d'État de ma sœur
kinésithérapeute relève comme vous le
savez de la compétence de la ministre
des Affaires euh sociales et de la santé
en vue de son inscription dans le schéma
LMD Licence Master Doctorat défin à
Lisbonne cette à Bologne pardon cette
formation a fait l'objet d'un travail
interministériel d'un premier travail
interministériel le pour le ministère de
la santé il concernait la définition des
référentiels de compétences et pour le
ministère d'enseignement supérieur et de
la recherche des modalités de la
formation et des référentiels pour la
formation les premiers résultats ont
fait l'objet vous l'avez dit d'un
communiqué de presse le 25 février
dernier il apporte des réponses précises
aux questions que vous
poser première réponse le diplôme
d'exercice de massur kinésithérapeute
sera reconnu au grade de licence mais
obtenu à l'issue d'une formation
incluant une première année
universitaire qui sera généralisée ceci
permet l'inscription directe en 2e année
de Master 2 pour les étudiants qui le
souhaitent cette intégration de l'année
de préparation aux études dans le
parcours de formation initiale est une
réelle avancée dans la reconnaissance
universitaire et reposera sur une
obligation de convention des instituts
de formation avec l'université ceci
implique d'en faire non seulement une
année de sélection et d'orientation mais
aussi une année de formation à
partentière deè point le
conventionnement des instituts de
formation avec université sera
obligatoire l'absence de convention
entraînera le retrait de l'autorisation
de délivrance de la formation trè point
l'inscription dans la convention avec
l'université devra faire apparaître une
offre de Master 2 à laquelle les
diplômés master kinésithérapeute
pourront accéder directement un travail
complémentaire déterminera les champs de
pratiques avancées en lien avec
l'obtention d'un master le travail à
conduire par les deux ministères doit
désormais être mené donc être poursuivi
comme vous le souhaitez avec l'objectif
d'une mise en œuvre pour une pour la
rentrée de septembre 2014 ce travail
sera copiloté dans le respect des
exigences lié au domaine d'intervention
de la profession et de préparation des
étudiants à leur à leur futures
conditions d'exercice professionnel
ainsi que celle liée à la reconnaissance
universitaire enfin pour information je
vous confirme qu'une mission d'expertise
et d'inspection conjointe IGAS IgA ENR
est engagé à la demande de nos deux
ministères avec pour objectif de
produire des recommandations générales
relatives au processus d'un
d'universitarisation des formations
initiales des professions par par
médical j'espère par ses réponses
complètes et un travail en progrès vous
l'aurez compris avoir répondu à vos
préoccupations monsieur le sénateur
merci madame la ministre monsieur
Fournier et bien oui merci monsieur le
Président Madame le Ministre je voudrais
vous remercier pour toutes ces
précisions que vous nous avez apporté
j'ai bien noté que le travail se
poursuivait jusqu'à septembre 2014 pour
donner en partie satisfaction au profess
de santé et dans l'intérêt des malades
je vous remercie